this movie felt like it was bigger the  scale the scope everything about this  felt figure while we're shooting it it's  an assault to the senses  we decided to take to Alexis 65 cameras  to create real IMAX 3d I always like to  push the boundaries of cinema in terms  of look and feel and sound what so well  in IMAX because you literally feel  things coming towards you to feel like  you're involved in these great despite  things and you can feel the explosion  you feel like you're part of the madness  of this world oh no you guys are darling  what kind of mad you know what kind of  elephant go thank you  I don't know it looks great I saw it  last night in IMAX and I felt completely  surrounded by the movie not only is it a  great storyline that will unite people  but it's also a great experience you've  never had in your life  you  you